There is the age-old saying that “ignorance
is bliss.”
It suggests that if you do not know something,
than you will not worry about it.
But in terms of dealing with life, this concept
is not possible for a human being to maintain.
Complete ignorance may in fact be blissful,
but we as humans, have surpassed the ability
to be of the complete ignorance required for
such bliss.
Through evolution, we have come into higher
and complex consciousness.
We have come to be inquisitive and analytical
about the life around us.
We are the manifestations of nature’s attempt
to reflexively comprehend itself.
No human is exempt from this, and therefore
no human can posses the bliss associated with
ignorance.
Less cognizant beings like that of an insect
or a reptile can possibly abide by such a
concept, but we are no longer on the same
cognitive field as an insect or a reptile,
so we cannot live like one.
Therefore, we must not buy into the easiness
or superficiality of human idiocy, for we
are all of an intelligence that requires attention
and embracement.
You must work to achieve your highest intellectual
capacity and resist being pulled down and
diverted away from caring about the power
of your mind.
The pursuit of higher awareness and intelligence
is the pursuit of humanity itself.
And if you wish to be in touch with your humanity,
you must not neglect what makes you uniquely
human; your ability to ask “why?” and
work and fight for answers.
When we ignore this pursuit and neglect an
attempt to understand our being and the life
around it, we endure unawareness and lose
all chances of ever truly experiencing bliss.